in this video in the next few videos
we're just really going to be doing a
bunch of calculations about this data
set right over here and hopefully just
going through those calculations will
give you an intuitive sense of what the
analysis of variance is all about now
the first thing I want to do in this
video is calculate the total sum of
squares so I'll call that SST SS sum of
squares total and you could view it as
really the numerator when you calculate
variance so you're just going to take
the the distance between each of these
data points and the mean of all of these
data points square them and just take
that sum we're not going to divide by
the degree of freedom which you would
normally do if you were calculating
sample variance now what is this going
to be well the first thing we need to do
we have to figure out the mean of all of
this stuff over here and I'm actually
going to call that the grand mean I'm
going to call that the grand mean I'm
going to show you in a second that it's
the same thing as the mean of the means
of each of these data sets so let's
calculate the grand mean so it's going
to be 3 plus 2 plus 1 3 plus 2 plus 1
plus 5 plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 plus 3 plus
4 plus 5 plus 6 plus 7 plus 5 plus 6
plus 7 and then we have 9 data points
here we have 9 data points so we will
divide by 9 and what is this going to be
equal to 3 plus 2 plus 1 is 6 6 plus let
me just add so these are 6 5 plus 3 plus
4 is that's 12 that's 12 and then 5 plus
6 plus 7 is 18 18 and then 6 plus 12 is
18 plus another 18 is 36 divided by 9 is
equal to 4 now let me show you that
that's the exact same thing as the mean
of the means so this the mean of this
group 1 over here we doing that same
green the mean of Group one over here is
3 plus 2 plus 1 that's that 6 right over
here divided by 3 data points so that
will be equal to 2 the mean of group 2
the mean of group 2 the sum here is 12
we saw that right over here 5 plus 3
plus 4 is 12 divided by 3 is
for because we have three data points
and then the mean of group three the
mean of group three 5 plus 6 plus 7 is
18 divided by 3 is 6 so if you were to
take the mean of the means which is
another way of viewing this grand mean
you have 2 plus 4 plus 6 which is 12
divided by 3 means here and once again
you would get 4 so you could view this
as the mean of all of the data in all of
the groups or the mean of the means of
each of these groups but either way now
that we've calculated it we can actually
figure out the total sum of squares so
let's do that so it's going to be equal
to so 3 minus 3 minus 4 the 4 is this 4
right over here
squared plus 2 minus 4 squared plus 1
minus 4 squared now I'll do these guys
over here in purple plus plus 5 minus 4
squared plus 3 minus 4 squared plus 4
minus 4 squared let me scroll over a
little bit plus 4 minus 4 squared now we
only have three left plus plus 5 minus 4
squared plus 6 minus 4 squared plus 7
minus 4 squared and what does this give
us so up here this first is going to be
equal to 3 minus 4 differences one you
square it you're going to get squits
actually negative 1 but you square it
you get one plus you get this negative 2
squared is 4 plus negative 3 squared
negative 3 squared is 9 and then we have
here in the magenta 5 minus 4 is 1
squared is still 1 3 minus 4 squared is
1 you square it again you still get 1
and then 4 minus 4 is just a 0 so we can
well I'll just write the 0 there just to
show you that we actually calculated
that and then we have these last three
data points 5 minus 4 squared that's 1 6
minus 4 squared that is 4 right that's 2
squared and then plus 7 minus 4 is 3
squared is 9 so what's this going to be
equal to so I have 1 plus 4 plus 9 1
plus 4 plus 9 right
over here that's five plus nine this
right over here is 14 right
five plus 14 and then we also have
another 14 right over here because we
have a 1 plus 4 plus 9 so that right
over there is also 14 and then we have 2
over here so it's going to be 28 14
times 2 14 plus 14 is 28 plus 2 is 30 is
equal is equal to 30 so our total sum of
squares and actually if we wanted the
variance here we would divide this by
the degrees of freedom and we've learned
multiple times the degrees of freedom
here so let's say let's say that we have
so we know it we have M groups over here
so let me just write it as M and I'm not
going to prove things rigorously here
but I want you to show I want to show
you where some of these strange formulas
that show up in statistics books
actually come from without proving it
rigorously more rigorously more to give
you the intuition so we have M M groups
here and each group here has n each each
group here has n members so how many
total members do we have here well we
had M times n or 9 right 3 times 3 total
members so our degrees of freedom and
remember you have this many however many
data points you had minus 1 degrees of
freedom because if you know if you knew
the mean of means if you know the mean
of means if you assume you knew that
then you only would then only N only n
only 9 minus 1 only 8 of these are going
to give you new information because if
you know that you could calculate the
last one or you really doesn't have to
be the last one if you have the other 8
you could calculate this one you can all
all if you have 8 of them you can always
calculate the ninth one using the thoth
using the mean of means so one way to
think about it is that there's only
eight independent measurements here or
if we want to talk in terms of general
if we want to talk generally there are M
times n so that tells us the total
number of samples minus one degrees of
freedom degrees of freedom and if we
were actually calculating if we were
actually calculating the variance here
we would just divide 30 by M time
- one or this is another way of saying
eight degrees of freedom for this exact
example we would take 30 divided by
eight and we would actually have the
variance for this entire group for the
group of nine when you combine them I'll
leave you here in this video in the next
video we're going to try to figure out
how much of this total variance how much
of this total sum of squared the total
squared sum total variation comes from
the variation within each of these
groups versus the variation between the
groups and I think you get a sense of
where this whole analysis of variance is
coming from it's the sense that look
there's a variance of this entire sample
of nine but some of that variance if
these groups are different in some way
might come from the the variation from
being in different groups versus the
variation from being within a group and
we're going to calculate those two
things and we're going to see that
they're going to add up to the total
squared sum variation